good day everyone
welcome happy friday i'm jack van horn
from the university of virginia please
allow me to welcome you
to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series
this lecture series is supported by
uva's integrated translational health
institute of virginia
the uva brain institute the college of
arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a
grant from the national institutes of
general medical sciences
it is my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker dr
angela laird from florida international
university in miami florida
dr laird received her bachelor of
science degree in physics from florida
state university in 1998 and her phd in
physics
and medical physics from the university
of wisconsin-madison
in 2002 as mentioned dr
laird was originally trained as an
imaging physicist
but has transformed herself into a
cognitive neuroscience aiming to
characterize
the functional organization of the human
brain she was a faculty member at the
research
imaging institute of the university of
texas health sciences center in san
antonio
from 2004 to 2012
and is currently an associate professor
i think correct me if i'm wrong angie
yes sir bold professor she
congratulations
uh in the department of physics at fiu
she's been recognized as a rising star
at the university of texas
and is a top scholar um at florida
international university in 2013 and dr
laird and her laboratory
developed novel data analytic algorithms
neuroimaging informatics tools and
neuroimaging ontologies
to yield analytic strategies for
improving investigations
into functional brain networks of
healthy individuals as well as
populations with psychiatric
and neurological diseases and disorders
her research is currently funded by
several awards from the national
institutes of health
and from the national science foundation
dr laird's presentation today is
entitled progress towards large-scale
consensus
based models of human brain function
contributions from
fmr and as always we are streaming this
lecture live and for reporting via
youtube and if you are watching on
youtube thank you so much for joining us
also our specially selected 2020 2021
biomedical data science innovation lab
participants
are encouraged to submit any questions
for dr laird via the chat feature in
their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and i
will ask them on your behalf in the last
10 minutes or so of the lecture and with
that welcome angie thank you so much
we've been really looking forward to
your lecture thank you jack for the very
kind invitation thanks so much
um for that introduction i really
appreciate being here and
and spending a little bit of time with
everybody um
so just to get started uh as
as you mentioned i am an imaging
physicist so so this talk is sort of
going to
to center around functional magnetic
resonance imaging
um i started grad school back at the
university of wisconsin
and uh this was back in the late 90s
which was the early golden age
of functional mr research the medical
college of wisconsin
in milwaukee was among the first groups
in 1991 to demonstrate the ability to
image human brain activation using fri
with blood oxygenation dependent
contrast
and and those years um that was an
exciting time to be a physicist in
wisconsin
so when i was a grad student in madison
we were riding the wave of those early
successes
from folks like jim hyde and eric long
and peter bambitini
and just starting to learn um not just
about task-based activations but also
rest of state connectivity and there's a
lovely little citation down at the
bottom
a paper that peter banatini wrote that
kind of talks about this time so if if
there are any physicists and engineers
in the audience
um who haven't had a chance to kind of
um take a look at that
and and hear about uh that particular
error
i i highly recommend that you do so that
it was uh
it was it was a cool town to be a
physicist in wisconsin
so with that as an introduction into who
i am
and within my particular training um
today what i want to talk about
is that here in 2021 cannot believe it's
2021 i'm not sure what happened in 2020
but there you go
um our broader scientific community is
rightfully focused on the current
reproducibility crisis
and there's a lot of development for
amazing and innovative tools and
resources and best practices to ensure
that ongoing work in neuroimaging in
general and fmri specifically
is robust reproducible and reliable
those three r's
right but looking back 30 years ago
even during that time when fmri was
being developed as an imaging modality
a few groups were early pioneers in
looking at
consensus across studies and comparing
activations observed across multiple
studies
to determine where there was agreement
and when there was an
agreement such as in the case of the
anterior cingulate cortex
they examine experimental design across
those studies
and these two papers here being examples
of proto-analytic
studies that focus on somatotopic
mapping of the anterior cingulate cortex
and in the first paper that i'm aware of
that was published in 1993 by tomas
palace and colleagues
in that paper they examined various
functional
pet experiments that required hand
responses
speech and eye movements and mapped the
variability of responses
across the singular and this was
followed by a similar effort in 1996
so my point here is really to emphasize
that
we are really embedded in this
reproducibility crisis
but you know if you really look back you
can see that we have been interested
in reproducibility framed as consensus
across studies
for for quite a long while now and so
um we know we've known pretty much from
the very beginning that there are
limitations to any single neural imaging
study
such as small samples right compared to
other fields of
in cognitive and social science and
particularly clinical research
neuroimaging work fmri studies um
you know really rely on the publishing
of relatively small
samples which obviously can have um uh
are a significant limitation and and
don't allow
uh generalization another limitation
is that fmri in particular is an
indirect measure of neuronal activity
and by focusing on the bold contrast
then you know we do need to acknowledge
that our reliability is limited by the
biological and technical and
methodological compounds associated with
that contrast
another thing um that there's a lot of
attention that's
it's being drawn to recently is is the
publication of isolated findings you
know
we are all in a scientific culture
that emphasizes innovativeness and
emphasizes being the first one to do
things and so because of the logistics
and expense of fmri
additional experiments where you're just
confirming something that
someone has already published and maybe
extending it just a little bit
um you know there's not so much an
emphasis on that i think there's a
little bit of a culture shift that's
happening right now um but looking back
over the past few decades
we really have a whole lot of literature
that's all about isolated findings and
not so much about confirming and
replicating the cost studies
related to that is the the real
generalization that we do of
context-specific
findings and and here what we're saying
is that
we make a lot of inferences about brain
function and some sort of half a
mechanism that's based on
a specific observed difference between
two
imaging conditions and
you know given the way that our field is
sort of
framed um this really
is kind of a stretch sometimes so um
because of all of these things
we know that any single study may have
some
limitations associated with that but
um because of that
there is an opportunity to pursue
meta-analysis to look at
consensus across studies so all of this
is is kind of a lengthy leader to say
that today we're going to be talking
about neuroimaging meta-analysis
where we examine consensus across
studies by mining
data activation patterns that are
reported in the literature
and one of the reasons why this is
something that has really taken off in
fmri
is because fmri research generally
adheres to two community-based standards
we spatially normalize our brains to a
standard brain template
and when we report results of any given
statistical parametric brain image
such as what you've seen here for each
cluster or blob of activation we extract
the centers of mass
or the peak locations and report those
locations
in standard brain space as an xyz
location
and so as a result a given peer-reviewed
paper is going to publish the picture
of the fmri activation patterns that you
see here on the right
and those as the results of some
particular task
along with an accompanying table on the
left of what we call peak coordinates
which summarize those patterns and give
you a quantitative representation
of the brain maps produced by the study
and so our literature is chock
full of these map table pairings um
there's a lot of them you
if you spend any amount of time in the
literature if you know that
uh these tables are very much a
community standard and they're available
in the pds of all the different papers
that we need
and so from our early days we've really
been considering how these coordinates
can be plotted on the same map
across study representing results
observed across many studies
and so this was the initial evidence
that led us to the development of
algorithms and data analysis strategies
for formal
quantitative and coordinate based
meta-analysis
so one of the key things to consider is
that when i say meta-analysis
i don't mean that standard effect size
meta-analysis in which results are
pulled to determine if a statistically
significant finding
is observed across studies um this type
of meta-analysis has
in in some respects a sort of complex
history
and in some cases some sort of
questionable practices that lead to
in some cases essentially p hacking a
positive outcome
um you know i uh you can spend a little
bit of time with the clinical trials
literature reading about a sex seismic
analysis
and that's an interesting sort of uh
well to dive into
but for today i want to emphasize that
what i'm presenting is a locations
affects that analysis which instead of
asking
is there a significant effect across
these studies we ask
of the significant effects reported
across the whole brain
where do they converge so it's that
location emphasis here
in the coordinate basement analysis we
ask where is the consensus
so there's a number of different
coordinate based uh meta-analysis
methods that are available to research
but they all follow the same general
procedure
let's walk through that and then give
you an illustration of it
um if the first step is to convolve the
foci with spatial kernel to produce
study specific model of activation maps
we combine those model activation maps
into a sample wise map
and then compare to the null
distribution to determine voxel y
statistical significance so an example
is activation likelihood estimate
estimation i'm going to give you that as
a coordinate based meta-analysis method
it's a very popular choice so for
illustrative purposes let's let's kind
of see what it
what it actually does the general
approach here is that each foci
or set of coordinates is modeled by a 3d
gaussian distribution
we do the convolution to kind of
you know essentially blur those
coordinates back to the to the
uh spatial blobs that they were
extracted from
so for any particular set of coordinates
that you
observe across the literature we can do
the convolution process
combine those model activation maps into
sample-wide map
and then threshold them based on
statistical significance
so the idea is generally just to take
the coordinates
blur them all do some stats and then
have a summary map that represents
consensus across studies
okay so beyond ale
there are several other coordinate
basement analysis approaches that are
available to neuroimaging researchers
and these were nicely summarized in a
2017
publication um
and so if you are interested in
coordinate basement analysis
these are sort of your choices at this
point but then the second major
category um the second major category of
neurology met analysis is an image based
approach
and so in this case rather than pool
coordinates
or peak foci ibm is
the statistical maps the actual result
of whatever um statistical analysis that
was done on on your fmri
data these have better spatial
specificity than
p coordinates obviously and so by
combining these maps we ask
where do the images converge so
uh various different image basement
analysis methods were nicely summarized
in a 2016
publication um and then i'll also note
here that while image image-based
meta-analysis
is preferred given the additional
information that maps offer us
compared to tables of coordinates
image-based meta-analyses are relatively
rare there's only a handful of them out
there in the literature
and this is because a hardworking
researcher can dig through hundreds of
papers
harvest coordinates from the tables do a
coordinate basement analysis
and they can't just sort of magically
gain access to original statistical maps
those need to be made available by the
original authors
and that's why at this point
in the presentation i like to say hey
folks when you're drafting your name
scripts please go ahead and upload your
maps to neurovault these are
you know whatever group activation image
you have a correlation analysis
or resting seed-based connectivity
analysis anything that results in a
brain map
upload it to neural fault cited in your
paper
and that helps with folks who are
interested in your paper being able to
go
look and actually see your maps but also
downstream
image-based meta-analysis doesn't really
have a future unless all of us adopt
this little bit of data sharing into our
publication pipelines
all right and then so as a little bit of
a plug i will say
the previous slide listed a whole bunch
of different coordinate basement
analysis methods and image basement
analysis methods
and prior to a couple of years ago those
were all located
in different different sources
different code different platforms and
and in locations and
and i want to say let's see this is this
is a graduate student of mine named
taylor solo
he has developed nightmare which is
short for neuroimaging meta-analysis
research environment
it is a python package that integrates
all of these different
algorithms and methods for neuroimaging
meta-analysis
and places everything in a common
interface um
it's python based it's open source
we're very collaborative that if you're
interested in contributing to this
package and joining
this particular ecosystem that ties in
with night pipe my stats and nylon that
we
we welcome everyone's contributions if
you just want to use meta-analysis then
then this is the place that we now
recommend that you go
since it is tightly integrated with all
of these other different resources
so um hats off to taylor for the initial
work he's done developing nightmare
because it's really been a nice step
forward for the community
okay so that's all sort of an
introduction
to um you know the topic of this talk
which is which is meta-analyses
um and i i want to move now to give you
some examples of what meta-analysis
possibly can do for you
and you know with this particular
start of this slide i'm i could just
tell you that meta-analyses have gotten
hugely popular
um you've probably seen that yourself in
the literature i you know i tried to
prepare a couple of plots here that
illustrate that point
ale is one of our more popular
algorithms
um and then neurosynth is a coordinate
based database that's designed to
facilitate coordinate basement analysis
or you can do a lit search or just by
looking for keywords of fmri placement
analysis
and you can see that you know we're
working on increasing the number of
papers out there on these particular
topics
um but what i think is more important is
to give you an example
of you know how this can be used and
what sort of knowledge might be gained
from neurogenetic analysis
so the first example is a java
psychiatry paper from 2015.
in this meta-analysis the authors
performed a coordinate basement analysis
of voxel-based morphometry or bbm
studies
that examined gray matter reductions
across six diverse
diagnostic groups that included
schizophrenia bipolar disorder
depression
addiction excessive compulsive disorder
and anxiety
so this was a really large dbm med
analysis that included
a 193 peer-reviewed papers
um representing a total of over 7 000
patients and over 8 000 matched healthy
controls
now despite such a diverse diagnostic
group
they found that gray matter loss
converged in three
regions the dorsal anterior cingulate
and the bilateral insulin
i'll also note that when they examine
diagnostic diagnosis specific effects
they found hardly any
but they expect exception of some
distinction between schizophrenia and
depression and the other diagnoses
and to help interpret and give
functional context to these findings
they then explore the task-based and
task-free connectivity of these regions
with a parallel series of data mining
activities
first they examine meta-analytic
co-activation patterns using brain map
which is another coordinate based
database
and this identified regions that
consistently coactivated
with each of the common gray matter loss
regions
in healthy participants during task
task-based activation studies
in in which we were not limited to any
specific task domain
and then second in an independent but
parallel analysis
they investigated seed-based resting
state connectivity patterns
in an existing data set of 100 healthy
participants for each of the three
regions of interest
that are shown in in the blue here
and then finally they summarize these
results and examine the conjunction
between the task based coactivations and
the task-free resting state connectivity
patterns
revealing a tightly connected common
neural substrate that included the
bilateral
anterior insula dorsal anterior
cingulate and the thalamus
and so we've started referring to these
um complex
meta-analytic and connectivity-based
pipelines as metaconactomics
since we're incorporating tasks and rest
clinic tones
from non-meta-analytic data to enhance
our meta-analytic outcomes
okay so um in
summary then this work highlights the
importance of the insula
and the acc as highly connected brain
regions
that are linked to shared structural
changes
across trans diagnostic
psychopathological disorders
and um so this is a really well cited
paper that's a really good example
of how meta-analysis can really lead to
a complex series of pipelines that
really further elucidate uh
functional connectives and then the
second meta-analysis that i want to
highlight
it's another jama psychiatry paper and
this one from 2017
and whereas the last one focused on
trans diagnostic structural alterations
this one examined fmri brain activations
during cognitive and emotional
processing
in patients with unipolar depression so
not a whole bunch of disorders with just
one
particular disorder and while the first
example meta analyzed results from
structural studies
bbm studies we know that the fmri
literature is much more complicated
there are a lot of different tasks that
researchers have used to probe
depression
and each has its own experimental design
and analysis methods
so here we examine coordinate-based
meta-analysis
or coordinate-based results from 99
experiments
reporting on over a hundred depressed
patients
and in this figure we show the red
coordinates for increased
activations associated with depression
and blue as decreased activations
um again associated with depression both
for emotional
in the top row and cognitive the bottom
row
tasks so emotional tasks on the top
cognitive tests on the bottom
and when we meta-analyze these
coordinates
we found no convergence not for any of
the specific groups according to meta
analyze
not for the increases in activation not
for the decreases
not for the emotional task not for the
cognitive task
and i love this paper for two reasons
the first being that it's absolutely
fabulous progress for our scientific
community to get no results published in
general psychiatry
right but also for what the speaker is
actually telling us
we don't attribute our null results to a
lack of meta-analytic statistical power
we know from a previous paper that
focused on meta-analytic power that our
sample was large enough and we had
sufficient power to detect even subtle
convergence effects
and our conclusion here is the lack of
convergence across fmri studies of
unipolar depression
is likely attributed to a high degree of
heterogeneity across studies
particularly those that related to
experimental flexibility
and that's differences in experimental
design and analytic procedures
so overall this work points to a really
urgent need
for a strong focus on replication
analyses
um we need more of those in our
community particularly with respect to
clinical neural imaging
rather than continuing to really focus
simply on designing
um the the newer the more complex
new paradigms um new new ways of doing
things but to really kind of take a step
back
and put an emphasis on replications and
this aligns with the number of current
high profile efforts to really shine a
light on the strong
impact that methodological flexibility
may be having on our
neural imaging results the most recent
example of that
is the the narps nature study that came
out i guess it was last summer or last
fall
where a bunch of teams were recruited to
all
analyze the same data set showing that
methodological flexibility actually has
a really
significant impact on the conclusions of
those analyses
okay so those are my two examples
of what the standard meta-analytic
approach can possibly do
i like to highlight those because
they're nice compare and contrast sort
of examples
and now what i'd like to do is take a
little bit of detail but
dig a little bit deeper and show some
more detail about how
my lab is further pushing this
methodology um
and so to kind of set this up um i want
to highlight the fact that
we you know are seeing a lot of
informatics development in the community
and that means more resources
for managing sharing and meta-analysis
of neural imaging data
and this includes knowledge
representation systems and
it was mentioned in the introduction
that i've done some work on ontologies
which are machine interpreted
interpretable languages to allow
computers to compare
data across databases and the cognitive
data descriptors
are relatively underdeveloped so even if
you get a bunch of scientists in the
room
to kind of list this the the subtypes
of um tasks or paradigms that are used
or mental functions or constructs
um you don't always get a lot of
consensus across groups that this is
something that it's not like we can just
kind of
list different imaging acquisition
parameters that
getting folks that agree on how um
which data descriptors we have to
develop to
to annotate cognitive types of
constructs
is really really challenging and has
been so for
forever um so we put forward a bit of a
of a new approach using that analysis
that asked the question
why not let the data facilitate
consensus and so the premise here
is that differences in activation
patterns across a group of studies
should be captured and leveraged as they
potentially indicate meaningful
segregations in brain function
sometimes it's the differences that are
what tells us something really
interesting
such that tasks activating similar brain
networks
should be grouped as functionally
similar in the cognitive schema
and tasks demonstrating differential
activation patterns should be
potentially classified as functionally
distinct so the overall workflow here
is like with all of these coordinate
basement analysis approaches the first
step is to extract coordinates
from the literature so we put all these
tables and pull down a whole bunch of
coordinates
and generate modeled activation maps um
and so this is done
across a group of similar studies um for
whatever construct you're you're
interested in going after
um these model activation maps basically
take the coordinates blur them up so you
have an
estimate of what the original
statistical parametric look like
a statistical parametric image looked
like and then you generate a correlation
matrix that compares
all of these different activation maps
to each other
so that we have a sense of the
similarity across
modeled activation maps and then we
perform
a data-driven clustering algorithm on
those modeled activation maps
to identify clusters of experiments with
similar activation patterns
those clusters then can be grouped
and you can generate an ale map of those
and analyze
the resultant metadata every particular
study
can be annotated with metadata that
corresponds to the type of task
that was used in the experimental design
and the behavioral or cognitive domain
of interest
that was isolated by the particular
contrast that generated the statistical
parametric image
so here what uh i'll give you an example
of this
we took a large group of face perception
tasks that were downloaded from the
brainmap database
i believe there was over 300 individual
statistical parametric images that we
had coordinates for
and we clustered them to obtain four
different clusters
and what you see here
are the ale images that take those
individual clusters and meta analyze
them to come up with a consensus map of
what the activation patterns look like
within each of these clusters
now as i mentioned every set of
coordinates is annotated with metadata
that tells you
about the type of task what the
participants did while they were in the
scanner
and you can look at that metadata to
really get a sense
of the trends um of which types of tasks
we're using in any given cluster and so
what we found here
was that in the case of the the first
cluster the blue one here
the the map really resembled strongly
the salience network
which included bilateral insulin
interior cingulate and the meta
indicated that of the tasks that were
in this grouping there was a lot of
emphasis on visual spatial attention
and visual motor coordination two faces
in terms of cluster two um we saw the
amygdala
fusible and face area occipital temporal
areas and the metadata corresponded to
perception and recognition of faces
where the green cluster we uh observed
that the the map itself
resemble the default mode network
including medial profrontal cortex
and media precunious
and the metadata corresponded to a lots
of social
processing and episodic recall of faces
and then finally we had a little bit of
a red cluster
in the middle temporal gyrus and bureau
temporal cortex
temperpol and para hippocampal gyrus and
the tasks
in revealed by the metadata
corresponding to face naming and lexical
retrieval
so this is great is you know we did a
meta-analysis we did some clustering we
did some data-driven stuff but it's
always important when you do data-driven
analyses
to kind of take a step back once you're
done and
really think about what you've learned
that's new and
and how your results really correspond
to the existing literature
so we wanted to ask the question how
well do our results align
with existing um cognitive models of
face perception
so we grabbed a really well-known paper
um
that you know is sort of the very
well-cited
representation of the cognitive model of
phase perception and we kind of dug
into how that particular
model was pitched and we observed that
our purple cluster corresponded really
well you know
we're referring to this with perception
and recognition of faces
and in the convenient hacks paper um
there was a core system that emphasized
visual appearance of faces
and and posited regions that
corresponded very well to our purple
cluster
there is also an extended system in this
particular copy of the model
that incorporates person knowledge um
which
corresponded very well to our green
green cluster highlighting um
involvement of the default mode network
as well
as a little sub module here that
corresponded well to our red cluster of
face naming and lexical retrieval
and then notably one thing that was
missing is is that we did see that one
of our clusters
um you know focused on the
convergence in the salience network and
really
involved this visual spatial attention
component and that was not really
included in the new haxley model and
so in conclusion here we
were this was our first kind of go
at this and i'll show you in some
subsequent slides um
how we continue to work on this but but
this was sort of the first time that we
had taken
this particular meta-analytic approach
and used it to confirm and extend
a well-known cognitive model of face
perception where we
essentially confirmed with three of our
clusters
this existing model and then extended it
using the additional salines component
here
demonstrating that this large scale data
mining approach
can really inform the evolution of
cognitive models by meta-analytically
probing
the range of tasks that are included
across the literature and so then as i
as i sort of alluded to we've used this
model
a couple of times since in different
sorts of application scenarios
the first was on face perception um and
then in 2018 a grad student of mine
katie bottenhorn
did the same type of approach using
naturalistic tasks
in 2018 at the time a postdoc of mine
used this to examine emotional tasks
and then more recently we've looked at
reward tasks this is
another grad student in our lab jessica
flannery
and then we collaborated with some folks
over in germany
uh really recently to look at emotion
regulation
and so it's been a real fruitful line of
work to kind of take this clustering
approach in this large-scale coordinate
based
data mining approach to really kind of
dig into
a particular construct and really
synthesize results across the literature
and so i'll say at this point that
um i've been in this meta-analysis game
you know since the
very early 2000s and and staring at
these
maps you know for 20 years really
starts to to reframe how you think about
brain networks
um and so i've got here a a quick little
summary of all of these different maps
um that we've looked at
really recently from this clustering
based approach and
i got to tell you that when you sort of
take a step back
and look at the results across
constructs one thing that we really
noticed
is that yeah across all of these studies
we see the salience network popping up
we see the default road network popping
up we see the central executive
or frontal parietal network whatever you
want to call it
popping up a lot and you know this
really aligns
with um you know our now
accepted model of psychopathology
such that psychopathological processes
especially associated with mood
disorders
are commonly associated with average
connectivity
within and between salience network
fault mode network and the central
executive
network and this was really laid out
very nicely
in a 2011 paper by menin
that you know frames this as the triple
network model or the tripartite
network model that you know
does a really nice job describing how
the dysfunctional connectivity in these
networks can
really lead to diminished cognitive
ability
and diminish control over referential
processes such as rumination
so this particular tripartite network
model
is i think um really important for
understanding
the maladaptive network organization and
function in psychiatric disorders and
it's certainly showing up
in so many of our meta-analyses um that
are both associated with
um clinical populations as as well as
healthy individuals these these networks
are just simply very very important
um so with that i'm going to do
a little bit of a transition and
i kind of alluded to this just a second
ago speaking of these
large scale networks if you do spend any
time reading through the neural imaging
literature
you'll nearly immediately see a variety
of names that all
reference the canonical frontal parietal
patterns
you know some people refer to it as the
central executive network the cognitive
control network the dorsal attention
network
there's a lot of different names that
folks are using out there
and we were really curious to see if the
current state of naming conventions
for these commonly observed brain
patterns is
consistent or perhaps inconsistent
throughout the literature
and if it is inconsistent then
we wanted to highlight that that's
potentially a big problem because
that's confusing number one to call
different things the same name and
the same things different things you
know this can limit our ability to
coherently discuss
and interpret our community's collective
findings
so while most of this talk has focused
on
coordinate basement analysis this is
an example of what's possible with an
image basement analysis
we thought that given we were given the
fact that we were really concerned about
the spatial specificity of
the use of these different names
that an image basement analysis was the
most appropriate course of action for us
to kind of synthesize things across the
literature and explore whether the
labels that authors use
when describing their network patterns
whether or not they consistently overlap
with or are clearly separable from
different topographical and frame
networks
so that's my little intro there
we searched pubmed for papers that
reported spatial patterns
with the corresponding functional labels
that are listed here
and so that was a very intensive
literature search
we focused on studies examining data
from healthy participants between 18 and
70 years old that used whole brain
analysis methods
we grabbed a couple of maps from
neurovault that folks had uploaded but
for the vast majority of the papers that
we found
we had to email the corresponding author
and ask for help
in getting a hold of their maps this was
a process that took
many many many months and a lot of
follow-up um i could write a paper
itself
just on how you know lots of folks
didn't have access to the maps anymore
lots of times we had to go on a real
extensive easter egg hunt with the
authors
um it required a lot of follow-up and
that's what i'm saying is it's
you know image basement analyses frankly
they're preferred
but they are so much more work in
getting
the actual data that you need to analyze
um but in the end we obtained 360 maps
that were reported
in an original set of 188 publications
we took each of those maps we re-sliced
them we re-normalized them to get them
all to the same template and then we
performed a series of image-based
meta-analyses
and what we found was that
within a given label so like for the
group of studies
that labeled their maps central
executive network
no individual network label map
exhibited a correlation
of greater than 0.6 with its respective
constituent maps
and that that's the solid line there
so within a label there wasn't a whole
lot of
consensus between the labels so
comparing let's say central executive
network label and cognitive control
label
the average average maps for en fpm cen
and wmn those all exhibited a
correlation of greater than 0.8
with the average of all the maps and
then
the average maps of the van ecn tpn ccn
and dan
had a correlation of less than 0.6
and so what this means kind of shorthand
summary
is that multiple different labels are
being used
to describe topographically similar
networks
um but with that with with these
uh the 0.6 result there is some evidence
for some distinct networks
for some of the other labels but for so
many of them
there wasn't much distinction so
then the question becomes are these all
actually the same networks
so for this one we threw all of the maps
into a clustering algorithm to look for
clusters
of similar patterns and what this
re revealed is that while the label use
is inconsistent hierarchical clustering
of the images themselves revealed four
distinct topographical clusters
um and so with that
um yeah with that
you know the argument then is that we as
a field
need to do a better job in labeling our
maps
in a really consistent way um so as
as part of this paper that's currently
in review right now and available as
a preprint we are sharing these patterns
via neural faults and we do provide
labeling recommendations for future
studies
um there is also right now an ongoing
um task force for the organization for
human brain mapping that i'm
contributing to that's the ohbm
network nomenclature task force and
that's a group of individuals who
all have extensive experience in
studying functional brain networks and
so we're trying to come up with a series
of community recommendations
for how folks can go about labeling
their networks because as we saw in this
particular image basement analysis
there's not a lot of consistency and and
my feeling really is strongly that if
if we're not doing a good job labeling
things then that's going to have
downstream effects in how that we
discuss and interpret our findings
and so much of the work that's being
done these days is about functional
brain networks
so it's really important um it's not
just interesting from an informatics
perspective but it's really important
from
a community coherence perspective that
that we're discussing things in a way
that
that's really consistent okay
and that is actually the end of my talk
so i want to thank everybody for their
time
um i have an amazing group of folks that
i work with
in miami we have a lot of fun and
we certainly don't get any snow in april
so
i do want to thank everybody for your
time today and i'm happy to answer any
questions
angie thank you so much for that that
great presentation
um as people are trying to think of
questions
i want to ask a couple so one of the
things that is
great in my view about meta-analysis is
not only can you look for
as you say synthesis across different um
studies to look for
common areas of activation one of the
things which is kind of cool about
meta-analysis is also
incorporating information about some of
the study characteristics
and actually learning a little bit about
how the literature
tells you what the literature tells you
about how these studies are done
is that something which is um kind of a
focal
point of many meta-analyses or is that
something that's uh maybe not done in
neuroimaging but maybe more in other
realms you mean the different types of
tasks
i'm thinking of like different um like
you know proportions of males and
females
i'm think uh as a as an element of a
study um
country of origin like where was the
study done
um you know magnetic field strength uh
that kind of thing are
is there variance in reported results
which are based upon
factors which are inherent in the study
so this leads me to my little um
uh you know big community
horn where i want to say it really comes
down to our reporting standards
one of the things that is enormously
frustrating about meta-analysis is when
you have this nice
juicy stack of important publications
that have been out there
the variability associated with what
people actually report about
is so high that it it ends up becoming
hugely frustrating
i think that we do have the potential to
really look at so many
interesting aspects of variability as
you mentioned when it comes to
participants
yes the sex gender issue also race
ethnicity we are
and and and continue to be a very
predominantly
weird um uh uh field where
so much of our studies are are western
educated industrialized
i mean we don't have that
um high level of diversity and
inclusivity in our studies
and and that and the origins are that
because
so much of neural imaging is hard that
once you get to the point where you're
recruiting participants it's like
okay how can i just get people into the
scanner right so focus on the
technically challenging aspects of it
that we haven't done as good as a job
and making sure that our studies
are as diverse and inclusive as possible
and i do think that analysis gives us an
opportunity at least
algorithmically in terms of you can do a
meta regression
where you associate um you know
your activation pattern with some
external variable associated
with your study whether it be your your
sex gender ratio
or any of the number of things that you
pointed out
but finding whether or not a
a particular paper or all of them have
all given you information about that
thing
it doesn't happen there's so many
critical details that get left out of
this paper or that paper
um and that's why i really like to also
point out the kobeda document
that ohbm published several years ago
that give a real clear guideline of when
you are writing up your paper
please publish all of these things
because it's really important for folks
who go back to do data money the
literature to make sure that they have
all the data that they need
and that's why i also like things like
fmri prep
which these days they'll actually
generate an automated bit of text that's
output from the from the analysis that
goes directly into
the manuscript and i know there's been a
lot of pushback from manuscripts and
from from publishers about whether or
not that's plagiarism or not and
and that really gets a firework under me
because i'm like
we need consistency we need clarity and
communication and we need
comprehensiveness of all of this
information so if there are ways that
software can help us do that you bet i
think that's the right way to go
that's great and you had mentioned um uh
reproducibility um and yeah you've
talked a lot about that and i i
think it's so important to be able to
have
things like where you can look at a
literature from a meta-analytic point
standpoint and be able to make a
statement about
what's reproducible and i guess that
gets me to
things like statistical power
calculations and
getting an estimate of what is you know
how
often are we going to correctly reject
the null hypothesis
um because so many studies in the
neuroimaging literature
as you say you've done all this stuff
and then you're just grabbing
people who get in the scanner and you
may end up with a statistically
significant result
but you've got a sample size of 12. you
know
and i'm i'm curious if you have a
comment about how meta-analysis
might be able to help us to understand
what some of the implications
are for our statistical power and our
reproducibility
i don't know if i have a comment about
meta-analysis related to that i
i do know that my experience with abcd
is really
framing how i think about that in in the
sense of
abcd is the largest data set that i have
worked with yet i mean it's
close to 12 000 participants and
um the only you know really larger one
that i'm aware of is uk biobank
and you know a recent i guess maybe a
six-month-old pre-print that's
come out of wash use adcd group
is that you know the effect sizes for
some of the brain behavioral analyses
and maybe cd
are so small that i
really wonder about the plethora
of um i'm sorry
of um
studies that are out there with our
really small sample sizes
and i have been spending you know
everybody's doing
quarantine and pandemic a little
differently and i've been spending quite
a lot of time just simply thinking about
the future of fmri that if we need
these really large consortium-based
studies
to find meaningful effects and and
that's the key word these days
um and there's there's a really cool
abcd paper out there about meaningful
effects
um but if if we need these really large
multi-site consortium what does that
mean for a single lab
what does that mean for their future and
and the type of work that they're doing
so i mean that's a really good point you
know if you need these
major multi-center collaboratives
everybody using the exact same scanner
and exact same scanner protocols and
you're talking about sample sizes of
you know tens of thousands of
individuals to find
this microscopic effect size uh
you know that is a very telling those
are expensive studies they cost
millions of dollars and very often
they're going on for a decade
that's a lot of money and
activities that get soaked into that
that might not get
down trickle down to the individual
investigator wanting to do their
particular cognitive
activation task right right right
i mean i love the the small local lab
like here in miami
we live in a predominantly hispanic
latinx community
and so i personally am really
enthusiastic
about pursuing studies where we look at
hispanic health disparities
there's a dearth of literature in this
area and it's important to highlight
you know different experiences across
the us so i'm really wanting to pursue
that type of work
but i gotta tell you i do take a step
back and i try to think about how
to align my interest in that area
with my feelings about
power and um and the ability to
generalize and replicate
i don't have any solutions and it's
definitely something that's almost 90
states though
absolutely we have a question from one
of our uh
participants um do you have a favorite
meta analysis
methodology i do um so i was
involved in development of the ale
method from the very early days
i am partial to ale activation
likelihood estimation i spend most of
i mean all of the actual meta-analyses
that i've processed have been
ailment analyses um there's also
two different databases there's the
brain map database of the neuroscim
database
and i have been spending more of my time
with the neurostim database lately
because it is
it is larger than brain map um
and so one of the tricky bits is that if
you use neural synth you're sort of
wed to the mkda analysis method
and if you use brain map you're sort of
wed to ale
and and that's why i like to pitch
nightmare because nightmare kind of
takes
all of those different things and puts
it in a central python
package so now um we get to do our
preferred use case which is
to use ale in conjunction with
neuroscience data
what's the future of of brain map i know
that you've been
sort of uh disassociated with the
day-to-day activities for a while now
but um you must have a vision or
thought about how that is going to move
forward because it's been
around for a while um has been around
for a while
right and so um for those of you who
who want the back story i was in san
antonio
for a number of years and worked solely
on the brain map database but in 2012
i was recruited by fiu to develop their
cognitive neuroscience program
and so at that point i kind of stepped
away from brain map a bit
um and i'm relatively agnostic at this
point you know use whatever
tool or resources is best for the
current
case um in terms of the future
of both brain map and and neuroscience
you know i'm i'm not really sure i i
i definitely think they you know they
each have their
they each have their strengths and their
brain map is a manually annotated
database so they're actual
research assistants on the other end who
are coding papers and putting in the
database and manually entertaining
the task and the behavioral domain and
all the participant information
whereas neurosynth on the other hand
uses a web
web scraper a tool to kind of scrape all
the coordinates from the
from the html file
and and put it in there and so as a
result there's
you know some errors associated with
that and also when a paper publishes a
bunch of tables of coordinates each
representing a separate contrast those
all get lumped into one group so
strengths and weaknesses with both and
um
i would hope that each would continue to
go on and exist because they are both
really useful tools for the community
and i don't know if you saw jack but tau
just recently announced on twitter that
he is leaving academia to go work for
twitter
is that so wow that's a loss wow
it is a huge loss so my understanding is
that he will pass his projects on i
think to alejandra
vega but um you know this is the nature
of this right
we have resources that are developed for
the community and we like to think that
they will
exist um forever and sometimes there is
an evolution
and we move on to the next thing so
maybe there's a next thing
that that's for sure uh i can speak to
that experience
one thing which is kind of interesting
is the um
uh very often in the community and this
is you know neuroimaging has had its
share of these but
other groups or other uh domains of
neuroscience have done this too where
they have these kind of grand
challenges where for example there may
be a common data set
and they just had one of these right
where common data set is thrown out
and uh they say okay everybody analyze
it with your
favorite analytic method and then but
send your results back
or you know share how you did it and
share your workflow and
basically say what you did and then look
for commonality and consistency across
different groups so using different
methods and whatnot i'm curious if
perhaps there might be a meta-analytic
version of such a thing
saying hey everybody go and like look at
the
literature on working memory for the
past
30 years and do a meta-analysis of it
using whatever your favorite meta
analysis is and
basically putting ale analysis head to
head with
something else in neurosci or something
and looking for consistency or
commonalities
has anybody ever given some thought to
that no i don't think we have and i
love that idea angie this is it we're
going to be famous this is going to be
awesome i'm putting a link in the chat
but for those who aren't familiar with
the narps paper
i'm linking you to the website there
this thing was amazing
yeah very similar thing right here's
this data set there were 70 teams that
came together
in full disclosure are cited fiu
included one of those
um and just to see the different results
that you get when you basically say
here's the data but you go analyze it
they gave us like nine hypotheses to
test i think
um but full flexibility as to whatever
analysis method we wanted to do
so i mean if you're not familiar with
narbs check it out
yeah i mean super important point this
is uh uh
it's been a very topical thing in
neuroimaging because uh
neural engine kind of gets a bad rap
about as we sort of discussed its
reproducibility so this was an attempt
to kind of like
illustrate uh reproducibility and just
kind of the natural variation
that exists between groups analyzing the
same data set
i'm just kind of curious if there might
be a meta-analytic version of this
uh as well that could be a future thing
and you know you could tell people to
you know stick to a particular
flavor of cognitive domain you know
attention studies or visual studies or i
don't know whatever
um and get groups to kind of analyze
those literatures and share their
results that would be kind of intriguing
the um one of the things which is kind
of interesting and you didn't mention it
i guess i gotta
uh ask about it is you know where you
have the coordinate based systems
obviously that's something which is as
you say you can very
quickly go through and look at those
coordinates create
an ale analysis um and get a sense of of
what's going on
um neurosynth and being able to look at
the actual maps
is a little more challenging because you
just have those
you have the maps which is great but
maybe you're you don't have all of them
or
i don't know other reasons what about
the real data
what about the actual underlying fmri
time series and other things that go
into it and
what are what are some of the because
obviously going back to the raw data is
kind of a vital
would be a vital step uh what are your
thoughts on that
um what are your thoughts on it i think
you can speak to this a little bit more
clearly than i could
i'm just your humble i'm just your
humble host angie
you know i'm spending more time thinking
about that because
again of working with abcd data um
just because we're an abcd site at fiu
we're still held to the policies and
procedures for downloading abcd data and
analyzing it just like any other site
we're not allowed to use our own local
site we have to go
through the nmh data archive
so you know we have been spending a good
amount of time
figuring out like that's that's abcd is
secondary
data analyses right there's data made
available to the to the whole community
um it's different in that it's all the
same protocol
once you start thinking about um kind of
trying to mine the literature but doing
it through
raw data um then obviously you're
you're you're really coming from a place
where you're either considering
the open neuro platform that russ
buldruck has developed
which makes data sets available
or you know i'm sure i don't need to
tell you
the enigma model is becoming so
popular across a variety of different
contexts
we've been spending a lot of time with
the enigma addiction group
and we are in the process right now of
conducting some resting state analyses
on data that was collected across a
whole bunch of different sites and
there's not a whole lot of harmonization
in the protocol
and when you think about the addiction
perspective um you are talking about how
use substance use is uh
quantified and so trying to compare this
set of cigarette smokers to this set of
cigarette smokers to these alcohol
diffusers
it becomes really really important to
really think about
participant use characterization
so you know you're asking me to start
with something really simple
coordinate basement analysis and then
kind of go up a little to image-based
analysis and then go up a level
to getting in the raw data and
with each level you just get so
progressively more complex it gets more
powerful right because you always want
the absolute
lost data that you can get um
and so you know the time for the project
starts mattering like you said
having a having a undergraduate or grad
student sit down and synthesize the
literature
and coordinate basement analysis
particularly if they're working either
through brain map or neural synth
is a relatively easy project we love
giving those to students it's a great
way to get introduced to neural imaging
without all of the technical challenges
that come along with that you don't have
to teach them how to pre-process you
don't have to teach them
um you know the noise removal and
spatial normalization you can just have
them start getting
thinking about you know brain
function location correspondences so
it really depends on what your goal is
right as always
as always well i think we've reached the
top of our hour
angie laird thank you so much for a
great talk and a really wonderful
discussion here at the end about all
these
different uh uh pluses and minuses of
meta-analytic
data analytics and uh what the in
particular though what the value is
and how you can very quickly synthesize
the literature and get some
understanding of what's going on and
uh clearly that's been successful for
you and hopefully um this will be
something that others will uh
take a dive into as well um so thank you
thank you so much thank you everybody
who joined us
and everyone have a great weekend and
we'll see many of you
next week thank you jay have a great
time
thank you